so the fans thank you for coming along
on this extraordinary journey thank you
to all the people I don't know allowing
us to keep playing these games and keep
telling these stories thank you so much
for trusting me with this character that
you've known for over 20 years a really
loved playing Tormund
this has been a life-changing experience
being on this
I never expected people to like Brienne
of Tarth I was totally prepared for
people not to the fans have like given
me an identity that I didn't have there
are far more fans of the show that we
then we ever thought was possible it
would be nothing if it weren't for all
the rumors and theories and intense
discussion going on and the game of
thrones viewing parties keeping it alive
and when we take like a year and a half
break but everything has an end, even
Game of Thrones
hi everyone its charlie so we have the
Game of Thrones season 8 bonus episode
that's coming this Sunday which all
course do a video for but we also have
the Game of Thrones prequel that they
just started filming so we'll explain
what the prequel series is about and the
other prequels that george RR martin
revealed that they're developing right
now if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the game
of Thrones in A Song of Ice and Fire
videos there's a new round of that HBO
now giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video first big thing the
bonus episode is just airing like a
normal Game of Thrones episode next week
it's going to be like a big wraparound
there'll be a lot of documentary stuff
going on there's a lot of extra stuff
that they shot for the blu-ray which
they're releasing later this summer and
I don't know about a really big box set
but I'm sure they've produced a couple
extra bonus materials for that whatever
deleted scenes and anything they
released later this year of course I'll
do videos for that stuff but it's going to
be a couple months before the blu-ray
comes out so I'll just remind people
about that when they start dropping
featurettes and stuff the big thing
about the prequel that's going on right
now is the george RR martin just a
little while ago was talking about three
actually being in development active
development because there used to be
five one of them HBO threw in the
garbage and four continued on one of
them they're filming right now
that's the Age of Heroes long night
prequel series the working title for
that while they're filming right now it
just called Blood Moon which invokes a
lot of imagery I'll talk about the
meaning of Blood Moon in the context
that they're using it for the series in
a second but because George RR Martin's
said that there are two others that
they're developing right now even though
they're not shooting those of the two
yet I'm guessing on the list of
possibilities because there's a number
of different series they could do it's
either dance of the dragons the
Blackfyre rebellion or the rise of the
Valyrian freehold in the Dragonlords the
reason why they're probably going with a
long night Age of Heroes prequel first
is because it's similar to Game of
Thrones so it's familiar but it'll be
different enough that it won't feel like
the exact same thing because it's set
during a period in history before the
rise of Valyrian freehold so I'll
explain the timeline of events from that
ancient history because you have the
dawn age the Age of Heroes the long
night then the rise of the Valyrian
freehold the Dragonlords of Illyria
didn't really become a thing till after
they had pushed the night King back to
the lands of always winter and built the
wall
really like the joke that the night king
now after seeing episode 5 and Daenerys
just go all ham on King's Landing that
the Nagin helped build the wall himself
with his magic because he wanted to
protect the White Walkers from the
dragons of Illyria that's not actually
true that's just a joke that people are
talking about the wall was built with
the help of the magic of the children of
the forest the first men the Giants
pretty much everyone coming together
because it was happening after they
pushed the White Walkers back but
there's a lot of magical enchantments
that involve the powerful magics of the
children of the forest you also have to
remember based on recent context that
there was also a three-eyed Raven that
was minted during that period that's
probably when the children the forest
created the first three-eyed Raven it
would be fun if Brandon the Builder
became the first three-eyed raven sort
of closing the loop even though I don't
think that bran stark a present day is
the same brand Brandon the Builder there
was a theory a long time ago about bran
potentially being all of the brand's
because of the events have hold the door
when bran is seen back in time using his
green site but also working into Hodor
and present-day creating this feedback
loop across time space a lot of people
just thought that maybe he had something
to do with the creation of the night
king the way bran explains it during
season 8 episode 2 is there have been
many three-eyed Ravens when one gets old
enough and ready to die he'll select
another one or he'll use his green site
to find out who's supposed to be the
next three-eyed Raven and then contact
them through visions like we saw during
season one of the TV show when bran
started to get visions of the three-eyed
Raven after his accident thousands of
years ago there came a night that lasted
a generation in that darkness the White
Walkers came for the first time they
swept through cities and kingdoms riding
their dead horses hunting with their
packs of pale spiders big as hounds
so remember someday when brand thebroken
first of his name becomes old and up and
gets ready to die he will select another
three-eyed Raven to pass his knowledge
onto so even though in the books he's
referred to as the last green seer I
guess you could say that he will not
eventually be the last green seer
there'll be another one that's born
someday in many many years but the Game
of Thrones Blood Moon prequel that
they're filming right now is filming at
the Titanic studios where they filmed
the main show Game of Thrones but if
you've been watching the
behind-the-scenes featurette
from Game of Thrones this season they
show you a lot of Titanic studio shot
like where they built the big King's
Landing replica so that they could
destroy it during Episode five
they have all these giant crates stacked
up so we have no idea what it looks like
but the Watchers people on Watchers on
the wall got some pictures of them
filming in the area where they film some
of the Vale scenes from season six so a
lot of the locations will be familiar
they'll film and Northern Ireland it all
over the place but they're going to try to
make it look a little bit different
because this is 5,000 years before the
events in present day so here's the
thing about that timeline if you're
familiar with the Song of Ice and Fire
there's already a pre-existing timeline
of ancient events that we know about
George Martin came out recently it was
like yeah you know that's not completely
accurate some of those events weren't
quite so far apart as we believe there
were some Samwell scenes during season
seven trying to address some of those
factual inaccuracies about history the
maesters tried to be as accurate as
possible but the tales of the long night
can't be pure fabrication too many
similarities from unconnected sources
and thousands of years before that
during the long night we can forgive
them for thinking it truly was the end
but it wasn't none of it was the wall
stood through it all every winter that
ever came has ended well when he's
talking to maester ebro's they talk
about how history can be twisted just a
little bit if it's not recorded very
accurately and the maesters didn't
really become a thing till much much
later in the timeline recently George
our Martin said that the series is
taking place around 5,000 years ago but
loose timeline of events leading up to
the events on this prequel series you
have the dawn age which is basically the
era when the first men crossed the arm
of Dorne to populate Westeros the
children of the forest start to war with
them they used the hammer of waters in
their powerful magics on the Isle of
faces to smash the arm of door and
causing this big Cataclysm it doesn't
work the first men multiply like a rats
overwhelming the children of the forest
numbers that leads them to eventually
try to crack Westeros in half so that
they could at least have the northern
half of Westeros that isn't completely
successful and it winds up creating this
marshy area that eventually became moat
Cailin so that's why there are so many
weird boggy marshes around that area
because the children of the forest
actually tried to crack
the continent in half the war between
the first men and the children continues
to go worse and worse for them finally
forcing them to create the night king in
the White Walkers then after the White
Walkers go completely ham on everyone
the children signed the pact with the
first men the signing of the pact is the
event that ends the dawn age and begins
the Age of Heroes so during the Age of
Heroes early days they form their
Alliance and they start to fight the
White Walkers back and they slowly
descend the long night the White Walkers
multiply and multiply you start to get
full-scale attacks and then you have the
events basically of this Blood Moon Game
of Thrones prequel TV series the reason
why there's a lot of meaning in that
name is because Blood Moon is basically
a total lunar eclipse basically
representing the long night itself full
night falling on Westeros way worse than
you saw during the one contemn one
episode during season eight I know
everyone was really upset about that
symbolically within the Christian faith
the Blood Moon also represents the
apocalypse in the second coming of Jesus
Christ which in the context of Game of
Thrones story is the azure high mythical
figure so now then picking the Blood
Moon working title makes a lot more
sense so even though the Valyrians have
not tamed dragons yet the balerion
freehold hasn't risen up you still have
a lot of really powerful deep magic in
Westeros at this time we'll probably see
the formation of a lot of the Great
Houses that we know in present day so at
that time during the Age of Heroes when
they form the pack they fight the long
night Lia's or high figure rises up and
they beat the night King back to the
lands of always winter here the
formation of House Stark the unification
of the north which actually predates the
long night so I'm assuming that when
this prequel series begins the north
will already be unified or it'll be
right after the thousand years war and
you see the beginning of the line of the
stark kings of winter supposedly Brandon
the Builder built Winterfell after he
built the walls so we'll just see how
they deal with a lot of those things
because it obviously took hundreds of
years to finish building the wall so
it's not like it all happened overnight
one thing right after the other
but there was house Gardiner in the
reach Garth the gardener the storm kings
of house de randon in the Stormlands
founded by durin gods group the castro
leaves of Casterly Rock then land the
clever who eventually formed House
Lannister after conning the Castrol ease
out of Casterly Rock we might see that
play out on the
equal series the grey king of the Iron
Islands in the winged king of the veil
so you have Winterfell storms and Pike
Hightower old town and moat Cailin is
castles that had been around at that
point but if you read a lot about
Winterfell history you know that they're
really only a few structures that have
survived from that original period the
very first structure that was called
Winterfell was destroyed the oldest
structure in modern day Winterfell
surviving now is actually from the time
of the Andal invasion that's the old
tower that's the tower that bran got
pushed out the window of by Jamie during
season one episode one at that time the
biggest cities were old town in Casterly
Rock the place around that that would
eventually become Lannisport but it
didn't become Lannisport till after the
death of land the clever so that
happened a little bit later in history
there was a town at white Harbor built
around a coastal fort called the Wolf's
den but it later wound up becoming white
Harbor I'm actually really hoping that
they involve some of the unification of
the north in this series too because
that's actually a really fascinating
story but I think it'll predate some of
the stuff that's happening on the show
what a coincidence big Easter Egg the
king of winter at that time was called
King John Stark the John that John Snow
was named for even though his real name
is Aegon Targaryen so what will happen
is when we get some more details about
exactly what is going to be happening
during season 1 of this Blood Moon Game
of Thrones prequel series I'll talk a
little bit more about history from that
period there's a lot of fascinating
stuff that was happening in the north
but in terms of the creation of the
night King all we really know is that
it's going to chronicle the creation of
the White Walkers we don't know if it's
going to start with that and that's
going to be the first event or if it's
going to happen over the course of the
first season and that's going to be the
finale like boom White Walkers created
everybody's screwed because they did
make it sound like the prequel series
obviously we're going back to 10
episodes a season and hopefully 5 to 7
seasons at least depending on how
successful it is that even though they'd
be spending as much money to make the
prequel as big as the main show has been
the last couple of seasons they're
trying to get back on a story level back
to the things that made the first couple
of seasons of Game of Thrones really
great so not completely discarding
character development in favor a big
spectacle even though it sounds like HBO
is moving forward with a couple of the
other prequel series as well it sounds
like they're going to only
err this one prequel starting next year
as of right now unless some big
production delay ends up happening later
this year they didn't say exactly when
it's going to premiere hopefully it'll
be sometime between spring and summer
they're going to be filming all through the
summer and typical Game of Thrones
seasons at least for the first couple of
season through season four would start
filming in the summer and they would air
their episodes in the spring so until
HBO says otherwise just assume that
they'll start airing episodes sometime
next summer I don't expect them to drop
a trailer or any kind of teaser or
anything like that so either the very
end of this year or early next year
typical Game of Thrones trailers drop in
January February but we'll see I'll be
doing bonus videos for the prequel all
summer long but if you have special
requests just leave them in the comments
below if there's any history videos that
you want me to do or any specific videos
on houses or people from that period
don't forget about all the other big
stuff that's coming to the Amazon Lord
of the Ring series The Witcher Netflix
TV series HBO's Watchmen TV series
there's a bunch of stuff coming later
this year so of course I'll do videos
for all that stuff there'll be more Game
of Thrones videos coming later this week
I'll name a giveaway winner when I post
those while you wait for everything
click here for my Game of Thrones finale
video wrap up and click here for my
episode 6 Easter egg video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!